I mean there's that famous Willie Sutton
quote right you know famous bank robber
you know why why did you rob banks and
he says because that's where the morning
is hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Jonathan bid
lack he's the president of the coalition
to reduce spending Jonathan thanks for
talking to us that's right you guys have
a spending pledge which is kind of like
the obverse of americans for tax reforms
tax pledge you ask politicians or people
to sign on the dotted line saying that
every kind of spending is on the table
whatever your personal orientation is
and also that you will vote against any
increase in spending unless it's offset
by spending cuts why is spending so
important so Milton Friedman of course
said that the true cost of government is
what we spend not what we tax and we
ultimately have to pay for this right so
if we're not paying for it now we pay
for it tomorrow and that generally is
through borrowing or the Fed printing
money and so that has cost to the
economy I mean Ken Rogoff of Harvard did
a study that basically showed that when
debt to GDP gets to about ninety percent
growth lags so people today where are we
now well public that GD is around 70 or
so okay but then when you take it all of
it including what the government owes to
other parts of the gully where North
Laurel that's right yeah that's right so
spending I mean and this is something
that's been a long time coming because
people on the kind of free market right
whether they're libertarians and
conservatives have always stressed taxes
you know we need to reduce taxes to spur
growth and things like that liberals
have always wanted to jack up taxes but
people have not spent that much time
focusing on spending under George Bush
adjusted for inflation real spending
went up in eight years about sixty or so
percent are we at a breaking point where
we really need to get spending under
control or it's it's game over I think
so I mean I think for a long time you
will focus on taxes because it was kind
of easy right I mean we didn't think
that people were actually be willing to
borrow to the degree that that we are
today so there was the whole notion of
star of the beast right if we take away
the if we take away the money from
government they'll have to cut spending
we know now that's not the case because
there are other means of getting access
to capital right and we're borrowing
about or were spent we're barring about
forty cents of every dollar the
government's
so the government's on track this year
to federal government to spend about 3.6
trillion dollars spending has gone up
even after sequestration has taken place
and we will spend more this year than
last year what's the proper level of
federal spending how do you you know
that's kind of a normative thing you're
saying like there's a there's a point
over which we should not go how do we
know what that point is yeah I mean so
that comes down to what your view of
government is right and there are
obviously going to be wildly divergent
opinions on whether or not you know we
should be spending on this that or the
other thing I think what it really comes
down to those that we have to start
thinking about spending in terms of
trade-offs so as you know a lot of times
we get politicians who say we need this
program therefore we're going to
allocate funding for it but we don't
actually consider the fact that well
it's increasing our total spending and
so I think we kind of act in a way
that's not really the way a business or
a household would act which is to think
you know if we're going to spend money
on this then we may not be able to spend
money on the other thing and so that's
kind of what we're trying to advocate
for is this notion that there are costs
to spending if you want to spend on
something in particular that's fine but
cut something somewhere else how does
this play out in terms of say you know
the Iraq war is a good example or the
Iraq and Afghanistan wars under
President Bush those were generally
covered through borrowing or kind of
emergency procreation bill so they
didn't go through regular budgeting
process you guys would be against that
type of thing sure sure and then now I
mean Barack Obama you know spending
jacked up between two thousand eight and
two thousand nine fiscal year because of
tarp and stimulus and all of that it's
actually been stable since then you know
but again we're spending 30 it'sit's
just stable as a percentage right but of
course we're spending so much more now
so even if you're adding if you're
adding the same amount of new spending
as George Bush was adding will that
percentage is gonna be lower just
because total spending is let's let's
talk about what are what are the things
that if you had your way that would be
cut right now I mean if we're spending
three and a half three point six
trillion dollars we're raising you know
maybe three trillion dollars in revenue
what do we do to pull spending down so I
mean there's that famous Willie Sutton
quote right you know famous bank robber
you know why why did you rob banks and
he says it's because that's where the
money is and so if you're serious about
balancing the budget and you're serious
about cutting spending you have to
look at those parts of the budget where
to spend things actually that's defense
Medicare Social Security Don and it's in
its entitlement spending and so you know
we can of course talk about the sort of
little things nibbling on the edge but
if you know when you're borrowing wit
forty percent you know that that you
have to look at those big table defense
spending is up you know in real terms
seventy percent since you know the 2001
since nine eleven basically do I mean
can we just say you know what the
Pentagon budget should be half so I
think there are I think there are a
couple of things why the Pentagon budget
is important one is that if you take the
Pentagon budget off the table you make
it very easy for other people to take
entitlements off the table right so part
of the reason we stress in our pledge
this idea that all spending is on the
table is because that's how you actually
are going to start to have a compromise
that's not I'm going to come together
and vote for your spending if you vote
for mine but I'm going to come together
and cut my spending if you're willing to
cut yours the other thing is of course
just that you know conservatives
libertarians have critiques of
government agencies about in
efficiencies and whatnot and that
applies the Pentagon and you know in the
Pentagon spending might even be worse
than a normal agency because people are
like okay well this is a truly
constitutional patriotic duty we're not
going to look too closely when the
general say we absolutely need this
right but you know there are a lot of a
lot of ideas on the table is how as to
how we can reduce Pentagon spending I
mean Tom Coburn has put out a lot of
great work on this you know we didn't
op-ed recently where we talked about
ideas not just rum Coburn but from kato
and from the center for american
progress so you've got the right you've
got the libertarians and you've got
you've got the left so then talk about
entitlement spending them because a
Medicare is the biggest problem hearing
so security adds to it medicaid's a
slightly different kettle of fish but
Medicare is exploding it's very
expensive but I mean these are poor old
people we got to keep them from eating
cat food so how do you even begin a
conversation of saying you know what we
need to radically alter Medicare's it's
very difficult right i mean one of the
biggest challenges for someone who's in
my position advocating for cutting
spending is that it's hard to tell that
story right if you say i want to spend
money on medicare it's very easy because
you tell the story that you just told
right and so i think that there has to
start to be a narrative as to why
government is less efficient and
providing these services and not to say
that you necessarily don't want to you
know safety net that's fine but of
course a lot of entitlement spending has
something to do with a safety net and so
that's I think
really how that narrative needs to start
being being changed that it's not just
talking about now that's the narrative
but then there's the the kind of
realpolitik who has signed your pledge
so far you mentioned Tom Coburn is he a
good guy in terms of reducing spending
who are the other players of the Capitol
Hill that are really you know starting
to act on this message Coburn's good he
hasn't signed her pledge but Ted Cruz
has Doug Collins a congressman from
georgia has I mean you know and then
they're all the usual suspects me Rand
Paul is great on the issue Justin Amash
Tom McClintock right Thomas Massie there
are a lot of people who I think
understand that spending is the issue of
the day it seems very hard at least
since you know the 70s to say okay you
know what we're cutting spending or
we're keeping it flat I mean it happens
it kind of happened under the boat
Clinton years but you know I mean it's
like your canoe trying to hold back the
waves what are the ways to make that
yeah it's tough because of incentives
right there's a really great milton
friedman quote that i always like to
talk about where he basically said and
I'm paraphrasing that the greatest
challenge of politics is to create good
incentives so that the wrong people find
it politically profitable to do the
right thing and of course if you think
about why you know why don't we get
spending cuts it's because all of the
incentives are on the side of you know
of increasing spending its bring home
pork to your district it's taking money
from special interest lobbyists so
there's really no counterweight on the
other side and so I think if you want to
see spending cuts you have to show that
there's a significant part of the
American populace that's you know that
believes this is a very serious issue
that's concerned about it and that's
willing to vote on it and that's
something no one's really tried to put
together their role as this is kind of
the tea party right i mean in a way you
know what was fascinating about the Tea
Party is it wasn't a tax revolt it was a
spending revolt in its purest form and
it's early form and it helped bring
people like Rand Paul to the Senate do
you think will they be a force to be
reckoned with where their whole early
message was stop spending so much I mean
I mean I think the tea party obviously
brought a lot of people into politics
who were involved in politics before and
like you say a lot of that was because
of the spending and because of debt so
yeah I mean whether or not that occurs
in sort of organized tea party fashion
or whether or not it's just because
there are many more new activists who
care about the issue of spending you
know I don't know but I think that there
will either way there will be a
significant impact explain a little bit
about what you know just does
runaway spending or or spending that is
unanchored to revenue or to efficacy of
the programs that are being funded how
does that why does that slow the economy
down why does that create so many weird
distortions that end up having a problem
on act with you know on economic growth
right well it's basically because you're
wasting money right I mean a lot of
times you know I'll talk with friends
and I'll say and I'll say this that this
or that is inefficient and people will
say well why do you only care about
efficiency and of course the reason is
because if you're if you're not
operating in the most efficient means
possible it means you're wasting funds
and not using them on on other things
that could be valuable so I mean
ultimately if you're taking money out of
the private sector which is of course
what drives growth in an economy you're
putting it into less productive you know
ventures and so that of course has you
know businesses can't hire as much you
know then runaway spending or kind of
spending that is untethered to revenue
streams or demonstrated usefulness of
the things that our money is being spent
on that creates a kind of regime
uncertainty and then what I've been part
of the argument against just kind of
uncontrolled spending is that it
adaptable it's going to it's not just
sucking resources out of the economy but
it's going to lead to tax increases it's
going to lead to weird debt bubbles or
fiscal problems right i mean we see we
see that mechanism all the time right
that that you know we've got distorted
interest rates and that of course
affects you know effects investment
decisions and invest consumption
decisions i mean i think ultimately the
best way to think about this is just
like a household if you have a ton of
credit card debt right and that debts
coming due how does the household deal
is that household gonna be prosperous
going forward well you know it might be
down the road but of course that creates
a huge hiccup and sort of disruption in
the short term right and I guess Nassim
Taleb would say that it makes it less
anti fragile diet that'll destroys you
know it destroys entities because you
can't be as nimble to deal with
unexpected contingencies it's exactly
right and yeah the main thing I think is
the distortions that it caused and like
you talked about in Bob Higgs is written
extensively about you know uncertainty
created by by government spending let's
talk a little bit about how you ended up
creating the coalition to reduce
spending what should what you're you
know to line CV yeah well I work for Ron
Paul in 2008 as director of fundraising
had the idea back then actually in a
conversation with peter schiff and we
were basically asking this question why
does why does no one else talk about
spending and what can sort of be done
with it and you know it kind of occurred
to me that you know Grover has obviously
had a lot of success on the tax issue
but no one's attempted to apply it to
the spending side of the equation and
you know and if you look at the the term
of its movement in the 90s it's another
great example of using pledges to sort
of get politicians on the record and
then hold them accountable once they're
in office it's obviously little more
challenging to do that on the spending
side but but I think we're showing that
there's the potential for success there
and so what is your hope in you know
it's a come 2016 what would be your
dream scenario that we have you know a
dozen candidates from both parties
talking making saying look I'm going to
cut spending this much I'm going to cut
spending even more etcetera or what
what's your endgame what's your dream
scenario yeah so I mean like I said I
mean again I think it comes down to
trade offs writing people who are
actually willing to say we're going to
think about spending in terms of
trade-offs um I think that's an idea
that has appeal across the aisle one
great recent example was the the
legislation on superstorm sandy right so
Congress allocated whatever it was 65
billion dollars in new funding to the
victims of Sandy but Mick Mulvaney
introduced an offset amendment that
basically said we're going to cut you
know from the discretionary budget to
you to make up for that spending you had
five democrats who voted for that
without anyone lobbying at all and that
amendment ultimately failed because not
enough Republicans were serious enough
about not raising total spending so I
think the whole key to moving this the
issue forward is to start talking about
it in a way that can have appeal to both
sides of the aisle you know that reason
did a poll about a year and a half ago
that showed not just that independent
support cutting spending as highly as
conservatives but even a plurality of
democrats are in favor of cutting
spending to balance the budget so I
think the goal is against it to continue
to increase the outside pressure on
politicians because that's ultimately
what's going to cause them to to vote in
the way that we want them to vote and to
just over time get more and more to
realize that this is the this is an
issue that we have to talk about in to
prioritize it as highly as possible
right well thank you very much for
talking to reason TV today Jonathan bid
lackeys the president of coalition to
reduce spending for reason TV I'm
Nicholas